when people look at me all they see is
the spoiled daughter of the hotel magnet
I just want people to remember me for
more than my last name Lindsay Lohan
brings the Nostalgia with her new
holiday rom-com falling for Christmas
Christmas has come early this year and I
come bearing gifts one of those gifts a
little Mean Girls Easter egg in the
trailer so fat what is fetch oh it's
like slang from England
[Music]
yep that's Lynn singing Jingle Bell Rock
which we've all heard before remember
this iconic scene from the North Shore
talent show
[Music]
[Applause]
but back to her new Netflix flick
Lindsay stars as Sierra an Engaged Hotel
heiress Who falls off a mountain and
gets amnesia is it a dead body
sure could you please tell her to let me
out of here first we need to figure out
who you are
you mean who I am my name is
my name is so what are we supposed to do
with her I have a place does it have
room service it's like a snow kissed
version of the Goldie Hawn classic
overboard hey what goes on hi Mom hi Mom
they're not mine oh honey I was sure
you'd remember them and with this being
a romantic comedy Lilo has to have a
love interest right jingle bell jingle
bell jingle bell rock where am I
alrighty you went through the lost and
found are these used probably but you
know sometimes guests leave things here
by accident yeah Glee's Court Overstreet
is the man Lindsay's character
ultimately falls in love with I love
acting that's never gonna stop I'm
always gonna ACT Falling For Christmas
is Lindsay's big return to the screen as
an actress we last saw her as herself on
her MTV reality show in 2019. I got into
this because I love music and I love
people being happy and I don't like
people judging people and before that
she'd mostly been playing herself in
different cameos her last movie role was
in 2013's the Canyons
not happy to her who said anything about
happy would you consider moving back to
Hollywood no not not move my life no I
wouldn't do that since then Lindsay's
been living a low-key life in Dubai with
her husband businessman Vader Shamus I
like having my private life private
um that's important to me
um which is why I love living in Dubai
but things changed a little in March
when Lindsay signed a new deal with
Netflix she set to star in at least two
films for the streamer the second Irish
wish is filming now while falling for
Christmas debuts November 10th it's been
almost two days what no one's found me
yet I unclaimed luggage they're probably
looking for you right now find my
daughter you like her don't you well
yeah I think you should tell her
wow
look beautiful
[Music]
foreign